- [Instructor] We are
told a seal and a penguin
are playing a fun game of catch.
The penguin swims leftward nine meters
then dodges rightwards another 12 meters.
The penguin swims a total
time of eight seconds.
So goes to the left for nine meters
and then it goes to the
right for 12 meters.
What is the penguin's average
velocity during the chase?
And they say answer
using a coordinate system
where rightward is
positive and round answer
to two significant digits,
or really we should be
rounding our answers
to two significant digits.
So pause this video and
see if you can figure out
the penguin's average
velocity during the chase.
All right so let's just think about it.
Our average velocity right over here,
it is a vector quantity,
sometimes you will see it
written like that,
but sometimes when we're
thinking about one-dimensional
vectors people don't bother with it.
And our whether we talk about
a positive or negative sign,
that tells us our direction.
But this is going to be
equal to our displacement
divided by the elapsed time,
displacement divided
by our time.
And so what is our displacement?
Well we go nine to the left,
and remember our convention
is that the left is negative,
so it's gonna be negative nine meters,
plus 12 meters to the right,
12 meters to the right,
all of that our elapsed
time of eight seconds.
And what's this going to be equal to?
Well negative nine plus 12
is a net of positive three
over eight, and our units of
course are meters per second.
So 3/8 of a meter per second.
But they want us to go to
two significant digits,
so I'll write it as a decimal.
3/8 is the same thing as 0.375,
but since they want us to round
to two significant digits,
I'll just say 0.38 meters per second.
That is the penguin's average velocity
during the chase.
It would be approximately
this right over here
if we round to two significant digits.
But now let's think
about this next question.
What is the penguin's average
speed during the chase?
Pause this video again and see
if you can work through that.
All right now let's do it together.
So our average speed,
and we'll use r for rate sometimes,
which could be used for speed,
our average speed.
Instead of displacement
divided by elapsed time,
we're gonna be thinking about distance
divided by elapsed time.
And with distance we don't
care about the direction,
we just care about the magnitude.
So we go nine meters to the left
plus 12 meters to the right.
One way to think about
it is the absolute value
of each of these values up here.
And then we're gonna divide
that by our elapsed time.
And so this is going to
be equal to 21 over eight
meters per second.
And let's see 21 over eight
is equal to eight goes into 21 two times,
you have five left over, 2 5/8.
5/8 as a decimal is .625.
So this is gonna be equal to 2.625.
If they want us to round
to two significant digits,
it's gonna be 2.6.
So it's gonna be approximately
2.6 meters per second,
and we're done.